but we can't talk about some of the
aftermath of Super Bowl 54 that's where
we begin today because Kyle Shannon
coach of the 49ers had his end of season
press conference yesterday and obviously
one of the topics Jimmy Garoppolo and
specifically the question of where
Shanahan support currently is for
Garoppolo here's what he had to say yeah
I mean same as it was the day before the
Super Bowl I mean there's no different I
mean he was on his way close to Super
Bowl MVP and we all know we didn't all
then make those plays at the end but we
made those plays all year are our whole
team that's one of the reasons we were
there and whenever you don't make those
plays at the end in a game like that
first and foremost the quarterbacks can
get attacked and then usually the play
caller so we understand that's how it
goes you know I don't know that he would
have been the MVP if they hadn't blown
the 10 point lead because I don't think
he did enough to really stand out over a
Knick Bosa or a Deebo Samuel who I think
would have been a good candidate for MVP
if things had held 2210 but Jimmy G
would have been the MVP if he had
connected to Emanuel Sanders when
Sanders was open and the ball was in the
air and I thought hey this is on target
shows you what my depth perception is
cuz he flat-out missed him he connects
there he is the MVP and the failure to
connect their big cat I've been banging
his drum all week that's the ultimate
litmus test you have that opportunity
once twice three times at the absolute
most in your career you either seize it
or you don't
and he didn't so the criticism is fair
and regardless anything Kyle Shanahan
said at some level he's got to look
inwardly and say is this the right guy
because when those moments come in the
biggest possible spots can I trust him
to make the play based on what we saw
Sunday the answer is no yeah I mean I
think he would have been the MVP if the
lead had held because I think you're
forgetting Jimmy G was actually very
good up until that third you know that
fourth quarter I think what was he uh 19
for 21 or 18 for 21 he was efficient he
was accurate he had had a good game up
into that point it's just what we've
been saying about Jimmy G all season
long he's a he's a good quarterback but
can he be a Super Bowl quarterback and
when the pressure got tighter when
everything
I closed it on him that's what it feels
like it fell apart and you could see it
as soon as the pressure started getting
to him getting home and that Kansas City
front line was getting some pressure
getting their hands up blocking passes
everything felt like it fell apart for
Jimmy G and that's what that's the
difference between a Super Bowl and not
a Super Bowl and that's the difference
between a Super Bowl winning quarterback
Patrick mahomes who when the pressure
ramped up and you're in the fourth
quarter in you're down ten he started
making plays and Jimmy G didn't make
plays but Mike what what is the
alternative we did we do this all time
with quarterbacks where we said you got
to get rid of him he can't win a Super
Bowl what is the alternative
the 49ers are set up right now with a
great roster to make a run next year
again what is the alternative who are
they gonna bring in that will
immediately make them that Super Bowl
winning team when they were up 10 points
with seven minutes left to go in the
game I mean that's as close as you can
get to winning a Super Bowl let me ask
you this question before I ask you the
next question first question if Tom
Brady had been the quarterback of the
49ers on Sunday would they have won yeah
yes of course okay all right next
question then Tom and we talked about
this yesterday if Tom Brady were to call
Kyle Shanahan out of the blue tampering
notwithstanding and say hey Kyle I'd
really like to play for my hometown team
before I retire I think I can be the
difference and we can win a Super Bowl
together what would Shanahan say what
should he say he would say yes but Mike
the problem with what you're saying is
you have to be 100% sure that that is
exactly what's gonna happen
because you see it all time in sports
the most dangerous thing you can do in
the free agency period is to start
talking to the next guy when you haven't
decided what you're doing with the
current guy and if you start talking to
Tom Brady and Tom Brady is using this as
leverage to get a more money out of New
England or just have New England whining
dynam and say hey we love you Tom we
want you to stay and we're gonna pay you
whatever you want and then you know he
might not even take that but just the
idea that they'd pay him whatever he
wants maybe that's where he's after so
if you start talking to Tom Brady and
you go down that road where you're
actively looking for a replacement to
Jimmy Garoppolo and that falls apart
then you have Jimmy Garoppolo next year
that is where things can get a little
risky little dicey with your football
team when you basically have said we
want to move on with this guy from this
guy but we you know we can't because we
kind of screwed up the negotiations with
the next guy well let's set that aside
let's keep it as simple as possible
Brady truthfully says to Shanahan I'm
leaving New England I'm looking at my
next destination and I want it to be San
Francisco let's go do this does your
instinct is he'd say yes if you can lug
Brady in and and and pay him what you're
gonna pay Garoppolo and they can escape
Garoppolo contract if they move by April
1 they could trade him back to New
England if they wanted to I you know I
I'm glad you agree with me because Sims
didn't I think that you take Brady for
next year and then and you know people
scoff at this but they don't understand
the connection between Kyle Shannon and
Kirk Cousins
if Cousins doesn't do an extension in
Minnesota and he's the guy you get for
2021 after you win a Super Bowl with Tom
Brady and he walks off into the sunset
was 7 I the Kirk Cousins thing I don't I
don't see it as you know I know Kyle
Shanahan wants him I know Kyle Sheehan
has coach Kirk Cousins but I don't see
that is some huge upgrade to Jimmy
Garoppolo like let's keep Jimmy
Garoppolo a little bit of credit here he
did have a team that was 13 and 3 that
rolled through the first two rounds of
playoffs I know he didn't throw that
much but guess what it doesn't really
matter because he's part of that team
and you can't just take it all away from
him and he also this was his first full
year as a starter because he got injured
last year so if you're assessing Jimmy
Garoppolo I are you saying that he's
100% a finished product this is exactly
what he is
this is his exact ceiling he will not
get any better whatsoever I'm not ready
to say that so I would take the risk on
Jimmy Garoppolo maybe getting better
more confident finding those moments
versus having a known quality quantity
in Kirk Cousins
that you might have coached before and
thinking you get the most out of but you
know exactly what Kirk Cousins ceiling
is well and I like that you said that
because that leads into what Steve young
super bowl-winning quarterback with the
49ers Hall of
famer the last time the 49ers climbed
the mountain he was the guy he was
talking to the San Francisco Chronicle
recently and he said that Jimmy doesn't
know his ceiling because Kyle doesn't
trust him basically to find his ceiling
you put him in mothballs in the NFC
Championship game give this guy a chance
to figure out who he is and along the
way you find out who he is and you can
make decisions over the long haul as to
what he can do but big cat we know what
his ceiling isn't his ceiling isn't
delivering the ball in stride accurately
to a wide open and not wide open but he
was open we've seen other quarterbacks
make that throw we've seen other
quarterbacks make that throw in Super
Bowls and we saw Jimmy Garoppolo have a
chance to do it and he didn't do it so
his ceiling is somewhere below that
right you're you're blowing is it you're
boiling his ceiling down to one single
throw like you like if Jimmy has em he
can't make that throw is that what
you're saying he will never make that
throw I'm betting the under I'm best
crazy because but that's crazy to say
that he's never gonna make that throw
out well I mean how many chances you're
gonna have in your lifetime to even make
that throw my point is that worse those
opportunities are very few and very far
between and it is the ultimate litmus
test for a quarterback you either make
the throw or you don't with the season
riding on it seasons riding he he had
plenty of time he was able to set up and
throw you either deliver that ball
accurately which is your job I mean we
say all the time about kickers you got
one job make the kick for a quarterback
who's in a clean pocket and his guys
open you make that throw you make that
throw and he did so I mean he had a
chance to win a championship and he
didn't make it
you're still blowing it all down to one
one throw his entire career I think
that's a yes I am oh yeah that's fine
but I just say he could never make that
throw and I actually agree with the Kyle
Shanahan not trusting him enough the the
biggest problem I had with Colin was not
the play calling at the end of the game
it was the fact that he just basically
with a minute and a half and three
timeouts left in the first half said
let's go in the locker room happy were
10 10 against the Chiefs offense that
you know was gonna explode at some point
that was where the trusting Jimmy Jimmy
G was like non-existent
that's the message you're sending to
your quarterback saying yeah you know
what I'd rather not risk you throwing an
interception here and you know and try
to get
more points in a game that you know
you're gonna need points eventually like
you know the Chiefs offense has done
this time and time again where they will
explode at any moment and boom put 21 on
you in the fourth quarter you know
you're not gonna beat the Kansas City
Chiefs with field goals you still said
1010 that's fine let's go in the locker
room that was the moment where Kyle
Shanahan said I don't trust Jimmy
Garoppolo but I put but to boil it all
down to one single throw and say he will
never ever ever make that throw I think
that's foolish and that's why you're
sitting with me right now and not
sitting in a front office for an NFL
team I don't want to be in a front
office I don't want to be in front of
work you know you don't get fight you
don't get fired when you own your own
media company let me say this two things
two things first exactly rights the G
it's the big cat jacket shirt
I'm just making me feel tough it's
making me feel big today I'm ready to
I'm ready to flex a little bit like you
were all last week after you got all
your big money from Penn national all
right here's a are you up to two hundred
thousand an episode now for pardon my
type kids Wii U I don't know what you're
doing right now I can't see your joke is
reliant affected this show Steve Young
also said that at the end of the first
half what's the message you're sending
to the quarterback and he put himself in
Jimmy Garoppolo shoes and said what are
you saying to me when you're not letting
me try to score with the ball in my
hands tick tick tick tick tick I mean it
makes sense that you could look at that
and say maybe Kyle doesn't really trust
Jimmy Jean to put the final point on
that the fact that he didn't make the
throw with the season on the line shows
why maybe he doesn't trust Jimmy G now
you mentioned letting the clock run
before we take our break here's Kyle
Shanahan from yesterday when he was
asked would you change your play calling
the end of the first half here's what he
said I felt extremely good with how we
went by using the timeout there was a
no-brainer but then trying to work the
claw if we would have got an explosive
run on the first one then it would have
been a whole different deal but we got a
two and a half yard run and so the whole
goal was to not let them call a timeout
there so you hurried to the line to act
like you're going but then you don't so
you can ensure them the homes won't have
an opportunity and then we run a ball
and then we
make them use one of their timeouts now
it's third down and at least we've made
them use one of their timeouts we've
taken enough time off that if we don't
get this it's gonna be harder but it's
still a lot of pressure you got to get
move the chains there
they brought a corner of bliss Jeff did
an awesome job we got a big play and I
didn't have an opportunity to score if
we don't get the offensive PR I mean
that's all well and good but I can't get
past the image of John Lynch up in the
suite doing this right doing this take
the time out and Lynch said yesterday
Parag Marat a the the executive savant
who negotiates contracts and also does
some clock management stuff for the
49ers Lynch was asking him should we
take a timeout here so I'm assuming that
Marathe saying yes otherwise Lynch isn't
doing this but can you see me doing that
you can't see me doing no I can't when
the same thing Lynch was doing yeah I
know anyway that yeah it's it's I think
that some of the criticism of Kyle
Shanahan from Super Bowl 54 isn't fair
but the handling at the end of the first
half I think falls into the category of
fair criticism along with running it on
second and five up three points with
about six minutes left those two things
I think are fair criticism yeah that's
playing scared I mean listening to Cal
Shannon talk there you're basically
saying to yourself we're scared of
Patrick Holmes which I would understand
being scared of Patrick when Holmes but
the only way to beat the Chiefs is to go
and be aggressive offensively I mean
that that first half kind of told the
story where you had Andy Reid going for
it twice on fourth down and Kyle
Shanahan running out the clock with
three timeouts in a minute and a half
left that told you who wanted to go
seize the day take that opportunity and
win the Super Bowl
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports